hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem partition labels
this is a very interesting and somewhat
unique problem we are given a string s
and we want to partition the string into
as many parts as possible so that each
letter appears in at most one part and
what we want to return is the list of
integers representing the size of each
of these parts so let's actually start
with the second example this time
because i think it really helps to
illustrate how to solve this problem and
kind of makes it simple just starting
from left to right let's take a look at
the first character it's an e character
right we want to partition this into as
many parts as possible but each
character such as this e can only appear
in a single partition so what we would
want to do is just say okay cut it right
here right this is a single partition
great but we can't do that why can't we
do that because
there's actually multiple e's in this
string there's another e all the way
over here and our partitions have to be
contiguous as soon as we see the first
character and we see that it actually
occurs way to the right in the string we
will never be able to partition the
string here here here here anywhere
right because at the very least we know
that this has to be one partition and if
we do partition it like that this i
think is nine characters but we actually
can't even partition it here either and
we can figure that out just by looking
at the second character the second
character is a c now there's a c over
here there's another c over here and
that's perfectly fine but the reason we
can't partition here is because there's
a c in the last position only by looking
at the first two characters we realize
that the entire string
is going to be a single partition we
can't partition this any further and so
what we're going to return is we have a
single partition and the length of that
partition is 10. so this is the list
that we are going to return in this case
so you might be starting to get an idea
of how we can solve this problem in
general but if not don't worry about it
because that's exactly what we're going
to talk about right now so let's take a
look at another example in this case
we're given a string and the result is
that we can split it into three
partitions the first partition is going
to be
nine characters the next partition is
gonna be seven characters and the last
one is gonna be eight but let's try to
figure out how we can arrive at that
solution and how we can make it as
efficient as possible so let's take a
look at this string and let's use the
similar idea that we talked about in the
previous example so we look at the first
character it's an a now immediately we
know that we can't partition this at
this point right this cannot be a
partition if there are additional a
characters somewhere in the string and
not only that we could have multiple a
characters and we do we have an a
character here here here
and that's the last one now which one of
these do we care about the most we care
about the last a character the most
because once we stop here we know for
sure that all of the a characters are in
this portion of the string and that's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
create partitions where all a characters
are going to be here not anywhere else
in the string not in any other
partitions so wouldn't it be convenient
for us every time we see a character if
we could automatically know where the
last index of that character happens to
be and maybe just maybe this character
itself could be the last occurrence of a
this index could be the last position
where a exists well conveniently for us
we can do exactly that and we can create
a hashmap so we can create a hashmap
just like this one where we take every
single unique character in the input
string and we map it to the last index
that it occurs at so for example you can
see the indexes are a little bit messy
but we can see that a ends at the last
occurrence of a is at index eight so we
can map a to
the character a to index eight the last
occurrence of b is going to be at index
five now i could do this for the entire
string but we have a ton of characters
so i don't want to waste my time too
much but just assume that before we even
start iterating through the array we
build a hashmap just like this one and
the time complexity of building this
hashtrap isn't going to be bad because
all we have to do is just iterate
through the entire uh string so the time
complexity and space com the time
complexity will be o of n technically
we're guaranteed that every character in
here is just going to be a lowercase
abc character so the memory complexity
of this hash map is really going to be
uh you know big o of 26 so constant
memory complexity not too bad okay now
before we start iterating through the
array let's think about how we're going
to approach this algorithm remember we
are going to have an output which is
going to tell us the size of each
partition as you can see up above so it
would be helpful for us as we're
iterating through this if we maintain
the size of the current partition
ourselves initially we can set that to
zero and as we iterate through this for
example we get to the first character we
see it's at index zero but the last
occurrence of a is at index eight so we
can keep track of another variable let's
call it end you could call it whatever
you want but end which is gonna tell us
what's the end of our partition as far
as we know so far right because we see
the character a and we know it exists
the last occurrence of it is over here
so we assume so far we're assuming that
this is going to be a partition but we
don't know for sure just yet because we
have some b characters here it's
possible that one of the b's exists even
farther than that and if that's the case
then of course we have to update our
ending but in this case that's not the
case because the b's are actually uh
within the first partition so let's see
this algorithm in action okay so so far
our size is zero we get to the first
character our end is zero so far but we
know that a the last occurrence of it is
at this index so we update our end to be
index a we get to the second character b
the last occurrence of it is five five
is less than eight so we don't have to
update our ending
just yet and by the way actually we'll
be we'll have incremented our size we'll
have incremented to one after we iterate
the b or the a character and we'll have
now uh updated it to two after we have
visited the b character again we get to
an a character so we know that we don't
have to update our end because the a's
last occurrence is still here but we can
increment our size now to three we see a
b character we've already seen it before
okay now we see a c character we've
already seen a b before so we can go
ahead and update the size to four now we
see a c character for the first time so
where's the last occurrence of a c
character it's all the way over here at
index seven of course we're going to get
that from our hashmap in constant time
since it is a 7 we don't have to update
our end again so
we are good to go but we can increment
our size now to 5. now we get to another
b character so no major updates here we
get to an a character again we get to a
c character again no major updates but
at this point our size will actually be
eight now we get to
uh the last a character so now our size
is actually nine but what's special
about this position well this position
we're at the index where our end uh
value happens to be as well so what that
tells us is every character in this uh
partition only occurs in this partition
none of these characters are found
anywhere to the right side so that
basically means we have finished our
first partition and we want to take the
size and add it to the output good thing
we're keeping track of the size the
first partition is of size nine so we'll
add it to the output and then after that
we're going to reset the size back to
zero because starting from here we're
going to be looking at a new partition
so our size is going to be reset back to
zero our end pointer can stay the same
because we know as soon as we see the
next character our end pointer is going
to be updated anyway because we know
that this is going to be a new character
that we see it's a d character where is
the last index of d well it's over here
which is 14. so that means we're gonna
update our end pointer because 14 is of
course greater than eight so end is now
going to be 14 of course we are going to
increment our size uh now to 1. okay
next character is e whereas the last
occurrence of e it's over here which is
15 so 15 is greater than our current end
so again let's update our end value and
of course let's update our size now to
be
2. next character is f last occurrence
of f is actually at this position so 11
is
less than 4 uh 15 so no changes here we
see another e we've already seen e's
before they're at index 15 which is what
we have no big deal we see a g
and g is the last occurrence of g is
actually at this position as well which
is 13 less than 15 so no updates at this
point our size will actually be like
five now i think uh next let's get to d
this is the last occurrence of d we get
to e this is the last occurrence of e
and it's exactly our end value so this
is the
second end of the second partition and
what's the size of this partition well
it's seven which is what we're going to
be keeping track of but i'm kind of
skipping that so the second uh partition
that we're gonna be adding to our output
is gonna be of size seven so that's what
we're gonna do next we're gonna go to
the third partition so over here the
first character is h uh by the way our
size will have been reset to zero and
last occurrence of h is over here which
i think is 19. so that's what our end is
going to be at currently we're going to
get to the second character which is i
it's a little bit smushed in here eyes
last occurrence is over here actually at
22. so uh you know update the end to 22.
next character third character is going
to be j
uh last occurrence of j is actually at
the end of the string which is 23 so at
this point we pretty much know that this
is going to be a partition itself right
but let's assume we continue to run
through the algorithm we basically visit
all these characters we don't really
update our end because it's already at
the last index of the entire string and
the size of this partition is what it's
something like eight characters so by
the end of it our size will be at eight
and then we're going to go ahead and add
that to our output so you can see we did
the algorithm we got the same output as
they got in the example up above and we
kind of had to do two passes one pass to
build our hash map and then one pass to
actually build the output but still we
all we had to do is scan through the
input so the time complexity actually is
just big o of n the memory complexity is
big o of one because this hash map is
going to be limited to 26 characters so
with that being said i hope this makes
sense now we can jump into the code
remember the first thing we want to do
is do a little bit of pre-processing by
that i mean building our hash map where
we are going to be going ahead and
mapping every character to the last
index of it in the input string s so
let's go ahead and iterate through our
string in python we can save like one
line of code by
enumerating the string which is
basically going to allow us to get to
iterate through the index and the
character at the same time so i is the
index c is the character uh we're gonna
go ahead and take that character and set
its last index equal to i now this is
okay because even if the last uh
occurrence of that character isn't this
index eventually we will have visited
the last occurrence of that character in
the string and then we'll have updated
the last index of that character to the
last occurrence so this is pretty simple
now getting into the actual algorithm we
are going to be doing the same thing
we're going to be enumerating through
the index and the character of every
single uh character in the string
but remember we're going to be
maintaining a couple things one is going
to be the result of course which is
going to tell us the size of each
partition and if we want to you know add
the size we have to maintain the size
and we're also going to be maintaining
the end of each partition so initially
these can just be set to zero now as we
go through every character as soon as we
see a character we want to go ahead and
increment the size of the partition we
also potentially want to update the end
of the partition if uh the last index of
this character is greater than the
current end then we can go ahead and
update the current end to uh that last
index you can write it out like an if
statement like this but to save a line
of code we can actually just use the max
function which is built into python and
most languages we can update end to be
the max of itself and the last index of
the current character that we are
visiting so we can get rid of these two
and just have this one line of code
remember we know we can stop a partition
if we actually reach the end of the
partition so if i equals the end of the
partition then
we're done we're going to go ahead and
add the size to the result and then we
can go ahead and reset the size back
down to zero and that's all we really
need to do as we finish our partition we
don't really have to reset the end
because it's not really necessary in
this case once this is done
our result will have been built so we
can go ahead and return it and then run
this to make sure that the code works
and as you can see on the left yes it
works and it's about as efficient as we
can get this problem to be so i really
hope that this was helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot consider checking out
my patreon where you can further support
the channel and hopefully i'll see you
pretty soon thanks for watching